have oh you want prob the second part of
the problem
okay well let me see i
think i have
those with me but if not just take here
just take the second page
yeah i found here were the extra ones
i've got one extra copy of the second
page of the problems
for those of
somebody doesn't have problems four five
and six okay
um
so i wanted to first talk about how
these problems can be solved anyway
and on the solution sheet i started with
solution two
and then and then one
which one you want both of them
four five and six yeah take
both so i started with the um
answer to problem two just because it
happened to be first in the file that i
had prepared earlier but let's let's
first answer problem one
so uh that was uh
uh i think the easiest of other problems
i don't seem to have a tablet to write
on but
maybe i won't need too many
um
the first problem was just to be able to
hide something in the left margin and
this this uh
you can use
as i said for quotation marks in poetry
also sometimes there's a
starred section in a book and you want
to put the star
out in the margin instead of
instead of uh inside okay now the
solution to that one did
did people find that that was that was
real difficult the main thing here is to
get clear
the ideas of of um
how you uh expand the hbox
um
is when when negative blue is involved
and so for example if somebody has an h
box of any kind and then
uh the very first thing in the h box
would be h skip
minus 100 points
then and and then and then you'd have
the letter a
that's different from an h box that
has an a and then an h skip of minus 100
point
you see what the difference is the the
the first one says start at the left at
the reference point of the of the of the
h box then go backwards
uh 100 points and then put your a next
one says start at the reference point
put the a and then go backwards 100
points the width is the same in both
cases the width of a minus the minus 100
point
okay well that's the uh uh
that's the difference between negative
glue at the beginning and the end
um
and uh
so the solution to hide was just
to to hide something you you say hbox to
zero point
and then you give hss number one now
h box to zero point mean makes a box of
zero with so it's not going to interfere
with the widths of anything else
then i said hss number one
hss means stretch or shrink as uh as
needed
uh to to reach the desired final size
and then i put the the the final the the
actual thing in here so this will
stretch or shrink
in order to do the right thing in this
case since number one presumably has a
positive width this will shrink to to a
negative width enough to backspace
and then number one would come
if you had if i had written
the other way around and said hbox to
zero point
number one followed by hss
you see what that would do that makes a
box of zero width that puts the text of
one to the right of of where that box
appears
that's the superpose operation s p o i c
in the in the manual
okay are you
are there any questions on that
is there a more complicated solution to
that
this one uh this one is the minimum one
that i know anyway
uh well no actually there's a uh oh i
shouldn't say it but there's a way to to
save one character in this because
if i had left out the zero there it
still would have been the same because i
think when tech looks for a number and
there's nothing there
it finds a number anyway and finds a
zero but um that's terrible because uh
once i admit that then people start
using it as a feature and then somebody
won't support that someday
you can't always trust that that empty
is going to come out zero
but
at the moment it would actually happen
without a syntax error
okay that was problem one now problem
two
was this fanciness on s and some people
ask is it supposed to work perfectly for
all letters of the alphabet and uh
sometimes if the letter is a
you want to bring the text in a little
bit further than the width of the a
and you know there are other examples
um suppose
in fact i saw a strange thing
last night where somebody was using this
kind of fanciness
and uh but it turned out that the first
words of the paragraph were italic i'd
never seen this before but so they had a
big italic letter
and then they had to worry about
not only do we not have an italic font
to use for this for this thing
but we would have to also take kind of
of some kind of metallic correction
going in
on that letter so um
but my idea on this is that actually
this is only supposed to work most of
the time not all of the time
because when you're being so fancy this
is the kind of thing that people used to
actually take the letter and they would
act they would they would illuminate
they would draw
in many colors and gold leaf and they
would make little dragons and things in
there and they used to have time to do
that we have time at least to tune up
and take away a thin space or something
once in a while if we're gonna if we're
gonna do it i would say you out pat
if you have an h-box that holds it
hangs out it's the right to contribute
to the width of that h-box it doesn't
integrate with the h-box unless you add
the attack correction italic correction
would would would would otherwise it
gets otherwise that
is isn't there now in math mode the
italic correction is always added so
that's why you might think it's okay so
if you put a if you put in a if you if
you put dollar signs around a letter in
the text for example they tell a
correction gets in there and it doesn't
stick out
in in maximum but in in horizontal mode
if i had an h box
of some letter that
sticks way out to the right or something
obviously it's not going to it's not
going to affect the width because
otherwise my solution to problem one
couldn't work very well
because problem one was was making an
hbox to zero point which you know by its
very definition was supposed to have
things that stick out of it
so this uh this uh
use of negative glue and also the fact
that some characters don't don't uh
aren't confined to the limits of their
box
uh means then that it's possible to to
get
uh things outside of the the limits of a
particular box
another way was moving left in a in
vertical mode
okay so fancy was this uh fairly this uh
solution i guess that it unfortunately
it doesn't fit on the screen i should
have made up a special version with with
uh
which we could see on the screen at once
but we'll take it step by step the first
thing
is um
an extra level of braces around this
first part here we and that's just to
put it in font and then forget font a
so that extra level of braces where does
it where does it end well let's see i
get one
two three four
five four three two one
um
so i think it ends there
at the end of that
what happened
this is the em of of the of the capital
a font
this m here
no
in the next line
oh yes okay good because uh wait a
minute what's happening here
okay but why didn't i get an extra space
hmm
okay
condom again
um
it must be balanced since i took this
from a text file right so i got
one
well let's start from there so i got i'm
up one okay two three four
five four
three two one so i'm not down to zero
yet this is the end of it this is the
end of uh of the thing so i have the
whole thing in in brac in
in double brace in braces
so now we switch to that font a then i
save in box zero
a
um
a box that i'm going to use later so i'm
saving it
and um
incidentally i'm assuming that this
macro is going to be called in vertical
mode the very beginning of a paragraph
and uh
if i had been more uh careful i probably
would have said par at the beginning
because of any uh it's a sort of a good
idea when you're writing a macro for
general purpose use to if it's if the
macro is supposed to only work in
vertical mode put par in front of it
that'll tend to put you in vertical mode
if uh if you weren't already and and uh
fewer fewer runtime errors for people
who forgot a blank line before that one
um
okay but i didn't in this case i could
have stuck power right in there
then um uh okay save
inbox save save now a box h box
and what did i put in that box well i
want something that's chopped has no
depth
the reason is if i take this big letter
and i and i and and it's sticking and
it's sticking out below the line
then tech is going to say oh this is a
line that has a lot of depth and it's
going to leave extra space and the
second line is going to be moved way
down
and you probably if you work this
exercise or try to you probably uh
notice that
if you didn't chop it okay so we have to
somehow get i have to somehow get the
letter in there um hanging 12 points
below but not actually but tech not
thinking that it's hanging 12 points
below the line
um but 12 points is what i'm assuming is
the space between lines
so i make this now i make this box
lowered 12 point h box of the letter
number one
and then also i backed it up um
uh no eight wait a minute what do i what
did i back up let's see i nest all these
parentheses here
carefully
the
the um
this part is is
is being chopped
um
oh this h box here is being chopped so
so the chop comes around this part here
and then uh this
this is the thing that's being saved in
box zero so what's going on is that i've
got in this in this um
in the thing i'm chopping i lowered the
the letter and i also added an extra
tenth of an m
of space to the right of the letter
uh figuring that
that would be that would be good to so
that on the second line
the second line isn't going to look too
close to the letter
so that's what i'm doing i'm making that
box and i'm chopping it so that the
depth is zero so chop to zero point says
this
the box is exactly the same as before
but its depth is zero
and that's a macro in basic
uh incidentally the the chopped macro
used to be very complicated and if you
look at the chop macro in basic it might
take you half an hour to figure out why
it actually chops something to a certain
size
it took even more than half an hour to
think of it how to do it but that was
kind of afterwards when we when we
introduced more features in tech it
became
much simpler to
to chop and so the new
version of basic uh which is explained
in the errata
file to tech for example i believe has
the uh has a much simpler uh subroutine
that does this chopping operation it was
possible but just by by doing uh com
combining glue and all those rules of v
boxes and so on to to get the effect of
chopping a box to a certain given depth
um
and the fact that it was possible at one
time meant that i didn't have to write
any more code detect to to make it
to to put in a new primitive
and uh that was at one time
uh much more desirable then when we
found out we needed things like
to know to talk about the width of a box
then then other things then things like
chop became much simpler uh still if you
want a good review of of the rules for
construction of
v boxes and h boxes take a look at the
old chop macro in the tech manual and
see until you understand it um because
that uses only only a
a few of of text rules to to a few of
text features to obtain the same the
same
phenomenon okay
the first thing i did was save a box
that contains the lo the the letter like
the letter s let's say drop to 12 points
but the depth of this box is zero and
then i have this a little extra space at
the right now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to i'm going to do a hanging
indent by the width of this box
for two lines so the first two lines of
the paragraph are going to be indented
by the width of the box
and then the first line however i don't
want i want to put the box on it so i
say no indent
and and um
that's no extra indentation because i've
already said to hank to do hanging
indent on the first two lines so i'm
getting that indentation of the width of
the box
and no further indentation there's no no
indent says no more no no extra power
and then besides that one but then i
have to backspace by the width of the
box in order to get to the left margin
because of the hanging indentation
then i put out the box and then i then i
take away this extra space so that the
first word will will go on the line yeah
uh uni yeah you got the microphone
good could you use instead of the
if you could be using the n and then
after one instead of the
h5 minus one wb0 where are we h right
here
yeah instead of putting this could you
put in the
hangar hangar indent
up four two after one something like
that
hang indent after one well see i can't
both go after one and four in other
words um the hanging indentation is for
a special case that either the first the
first so many lines are either indented
or not indented uh or no i'm sorry it's
a hanging indentation gives you four
possibilities but they're all correspond
to rectangles this kind this kind
this kind or this kind you choose one of
those four
i chose this one which is hanging then
four two
now if you want a general a general
shape you can say par shape and you can
give left and right boundaries of every
line in the paragraph but uh
it's e and and that wouldn't be too hard
because it it
replicates the last one if the paragraph
goes further than the
than they pick than the given paragraph
shape then it keeps using the the
specification for the last line to
continue on for all future lines so um
so par shape would you just have to
specify the first and second line there
is a way to simplify this instead of h
skip negative one box zero i could also
have said hide box zero
um
you see because because i've just
defined the hide mac
is there a question pat was that what
you were gonna say oh i'm sorry i had
i must have got it by telepathy
good question
um the top line to be moved over well
actually uh i i that might be one of
those cases where where we want to tune
it again but the space will come after
this
after the a and there would be root
there there would be an extra space and
it might not look right
but as i said i'm willing to fine-tune
the uh uh
the particular thing if there's ten
chapters in a book i'm willing to to
work a little bit ten on each chapter to
get it because that's sort of a glorious
celebration time when you finish the
chapter
so you're willing to
on those grand occasions you're willing
to
get the spacing absolutely right i guess
that's why book
designers spend so much time on title
pages
you know they're half of a book on book
design to tell you how to design the
title page of a book it's it's
where they get to play around
do you think it would be much harder to
try to solve the same problem without
using saved
without using save yeah to figure out
the width of the box um
let me see uh i i have to know the the
uh
how much to do a hanging indentation by
and that's what i and so that's
that was so it would be
somewhat more difficult there
i'm not sure that is possible but i
can't see how to do it right off hand
um i i if if i knew how wide the letter
was
but i might have to add that as a
parameter that was the way i saved the
box really
okay the
third problem was the problem of um
of
of signing
something oh jim
a minor detail
probably you actually want the backslash
colon a to be right in there with the
hbox argument one
where
here you probably just want to have the
backslash colon a from fancy to be right
next to the argument one inside of the h
box and inside of that set of braces
where
here right
instead of instead of there
that wouldn't that would give me the
wrong m then here oh that could oh okay
yeah that's the reason i put it out
there right
i used it also down here that's pretty
good
okay
um
computers are
are uh
very harsh task masters and they they
don't uh they'll catch these things that
that i might say oh yes that would have
worked and then wouldn't work on the
machine and that's why it's always good
not only to when you have
problems like this not only to think of
how you solve them but also to actually
try them on the machine because the
machine will
will
look at your thing a little more
literally but there there are alternate
solutions but
i i i'm not sure some of them will work
i'm pretty sure this height would work
okay
the solution to the problem i mentioned
one way would be to try and get two
tokens one the second one has to end by
space
okay
first letter
is the rest of the word
and then check to see if it's if it's
empty if the next if the next one is
empty or something
right okay and then you could do a
special spacing for that in fact it
would be possible to make to make these
macros quite a lot more general that's
true
and uh and i i didn't specify exactly in
the problem the degree of generality
that was necessary
okay um
third problem was the cake was the was
the one relating to paragraphing
and uh and we wanted to be able to put
to move lines up and uh this is uh
interesting partly because
it actually occurs in mathematic
mathematical reviews and when i went to
providence one time i found that
somebody's job was to
take the uh
to take to take the uh output of the
typesetting program and move these up
whenever you could
because the types because the the
typesetting software couldn't do this
but it was it was worth paying that
paying the salary of the person to do it
because it saves so much paper
and and the cost of printing the journal
that it happened that often isn't that
true barbara
microphone
they feel very strongly about the style
it's not so much the paper is their
editorial opinions it also looks better
all right
uh to have it up there all right and it
was it was difficult to do so uh
that's when i began to realize the
the uh what the paragraphy mechanism
could do
uh
it took it uh it was
early days of tech when i when when i
ran into this problem
um
now
let's see how
how it could be done it's so we're
supposed to say signed and has two
parameters
the first the name and the other the
address say
okay well this is the solution that i
give in the answer sheet first of all
key one of the key things is power fill
skip zero point this is the powerful
skip is what
is what goes at the end of a paragraph
now this all already makes my macro a
little bit um
this is going to apply to every
paragraph
and so if you so actually in practice if
we if we're having this where some
paragraphs are not going to end with a
signature then we would have to redefine
the power
uh operation so that it would it would
reset powerful skip at the end of the
paragraph
or else no i guess it wouldn't be too
bad i could put the ordin i could
restore the ordinary powerful skip right
here at the end of this part and i could
and i could stick stick this powerful
skip zero point here because um
powerful skip is is looked at
i believe only at the beginning of the
paragraph routine right michael
i think you put another grouping
around powerful skip that
i see
to put put this in here and then
then
then put put groups before and after
yeah that's that's right lynn yeah i
think so uh because the powerful skip
will go away at the end of the but
during the time the paragraph the power
will eject the paragraph and set the
lines that would do it yeah
computer will tell us for sure now i
started with an unskip here this isn't
really absolutely necessary but i
thought uh just so i mentioned that this
is again a way that you can start a
macro that you assume is going to occur
before somebody has typed a space
in in horizontal mode some it's uh
you don't want it
really this signature thing to be
preceded by a space
in the two examples it wasn't but
suppose somebody went to a next line and
then said signed
this unskip would take away that extra
space
then i give a space
that is unbreakable
penalty an age fill with one l
which is uh enough to fill a line
comfortably and then i give a penalty of
80. that's 80 is a you know kind of
subjective but that's that's we'll talk
about in a minute then i skipped 2m this
was the minimum space that that i wanted
to allow between
um between here and here if we couldn't
if you couldn't do it with two m's
between then it would drop down that was
the that 2m could be varied to whatever
the style convention is but you try to
try to squeeze things so that there
would be at least two m of space uh
before the reviewer's signature
that's what the 2m here is
then
i
gave
a null
a null box
and
followed by a
unbreakable
penalty a thousand unbreakable
stretching
um
and um well we'll talk about this is the
hard part of it between between the
first penalty 1000 and this last h field
here but then afterwards comes the
signature itself so i slanted the name
of the
the person and i added it out of the
italic correction
and then i put a space and i uh
put the address in in parenthesis and
came to the end of the paragraph
question there uh
yeah it would if it was a very long
if if
the person's name might have many spaces
in the and the
address might have many spaces and it
might be sauntered to halt that too
something like that
and um
this signature would actually then
might might actually fit
take five or six lines but it would end
flush right
and there would be at least two two m
space between the signature and the
and the text of the paragraph
yeah good point
now um
what what do we have here then we have
penalty but but the unbreakable part the
parts that between the text itself and
the beginning of the signature
um there's only one place a break could
occur and that's at this penalty 80.
you can't you can't break that glue
that's not followed by that's not
preceded by a box or something like that
so
you can't break out of glue that's
followed by that's preceded by a penalty
so so penalty 80 is the only placebo
place to break so this is it says either
you break with it with and and pay 80
points for for for
taking an extra line
or you don't break
and
then you have to fit of course your
badness had better not be too bad
uh if you do break then the line
preceding the break had ended with a
fill the line after the break ended with
two m's and a fill so that the line
after the break even
um uh it doesn't
start flush left uh
the the signature isn't going to occur
right right at the left
at the left margin
so it's a fill preceded by 2m
and you could adjust that of course by
putting a different skip in here if you
wanted to but that's the case if you do
break you paid a penalty of 80
and the badness on the on the two lines
that have the fill in is is essentially
zero so so so the badness part of the of
the demerits is is is negligible on
those two lines that that
had that
where the break occurred
but if you did not break
then um you've got a badness of zero on
the line where no break occurred what
but what's the total amount of glue is
two m's
plus fill
plus filler okay
notice the hbox null here you know why
that was there that was to always be so
so that uh this h fill wouldn't
disappear after the break after this
after breaking out the penalty you wipe
off the following glue until you get to
another box so this box stops that
operation
another question
why the 80
um that was the uh that was uh
similar to other penalties uh
hyphenation was 50 and
i don't know
i tend to think now this is something
that i did when i wrote the line
breaking paper months ago and i tend to
think now i'd raise that to a couple
hundred
um the reason was that
we found a case where somebody would
prefer
to to take
uh to to to drop
so we had we had one coming down here
and then the next line came it came
afterwards we said why did tech prefer
that and the reason was there was a
hyphen here on the second last line now
tech adds something a penalty for
hyphenating the second last line of a
paragraph so putting moving this up here
would have looked like the second last
line of a paragraph was hyphenated and
it charged that extra little penalty so
i make this i have to make this high
enough that it won't won't
prefer that just because of a second
last line of a paragraph hyphenated
thing tony
as a as a less elegant but perhaps more
structured solution could you save the
signature away in a box and then compare
dimensions with space remaining on the
line and make it conditional um i uh the
saving the signature away in the box
would would uh
fail only when the signature is supposed
to go over expand more than one line
that doesn't happen too often but it
does happen
that that they sometimes give a very
long
a very long signature so that was the so
so uh it would it would work however uh
wait a minute the the first part of it
that's all i listened to what was the
rest of your solution
well i don't know whether you can
compare the the width of that box that
you've saved away with the remaining
space on the line and make it make a
conditional decision in tech source
language
the only thing that that
that would do that would be the uh the
calculation of of uh if it were
displayed
so then what you could do is you would
save the signature in a box you would
right justify it then you would you
would set the disk a skip
to be zero and the disk b skip to be
zero
and the disk skip to be zero and then
you would set that as a displayed
formula and it would it would no i'm
sorry you'd set the disc a step to be
negative 12 points and then it would set
that displayed formula by moving it up
because the only thing in tech that
really checks the width of the x
of the line right now as tech is now
constituted is the
is the displaying of a formula and then
it it uses just a and b skip uh for
following a short line but but not the
other that would have been a solution
but
it's hard to say that's either more
structured or more elegant
if if we were if we had a way to to to
to go in and and look at the at the the
width of the last line on a paragraph uh
built-in detect then then that would
that would be a a another way to do it
but but actually i i prefer the the i
prefer to use the solution that that
ties it in with the optimizing
calculation because this will also
this will also try to save a line at the
end of the paragraph by because they see
the first part of that paragraph has
many ways of being set and instead of
saying let's let's be so if it might be
better than to move to to do something
different in the first part of the
paragraph so that we can get the
signature in there and void the penalty
and uh and so that'll all all be taken
care of in the same
in the same way
but using the solution david
that's right i did make i i i
i uh
i'll repeat the question uh he pointed
out that i made a mistake when i i said
you would get you would get an a at
least two m's on the next line
uh and and that's that's false if you
broke at the penalty 80 this a skip two
m goes away and the next line would just
have the h fill so the next line
signature might in fact come out left
justified if you didn't want that you
should
for example
well i'd put an eight skip one m here
and an eight skip one m on the next line
then i would have always at least two
m's but uh at least one m at the left of
the next line
yeah thanks for catching me on that one
another question in the back question if
you're willing to do with a penalty zero
where you have the penalty eighty could
you then dispense with the penalty one
thousands
if i
willing to do with the penalty zero
would could i dispense with the penalty
1000 so that would say then that you
would
skip break at the h fill or not no then
you see you you would never break at the
h skip 2 m you would break at the h
filth
and that would be kind of disastrous
because then it would insist that uh
that the line that the previous line end
flush right
the h fill is
is is uh
that would that would force tech to
bring
to bring this word added flush right
yeah um it's it's uh it's good to um
it it yeah it's not easy to get it
to to get all this in your mind you know
it takes it only three or four years it
took me yeah
before today i don't know how long it
took before i started getting to to to
feel the way
the way these paragraphs work under the
optimization criterion but uh it is
possible to learn it anyway that's all i
can say
but it is a higher level um
it's not as easy as a deterministic
method when you're when you're using an
optimizing scheme um and uh so so so
here we're we're allowing uh that we're
we're
not in control
we're saying
do your own thing tech paragraphing
mechanism and and we're giving it
guidelines but we're not in control and
this is a little bit hard for us to
to give up
um our
our general ideas but
you can and it and you can enjoy it too
afterwards i feel that uh some of these
details though are are are definitely in
i have to say that to design a
a beautiful
format routine for tech is is a
level of difficulty harder than for
other type setting systems the the the i
don't think it's more difficult for the
user of the format systems to do the
typing but for the designer i think the
designing
has to be because it has this
optimization component in it is is not
uh
simpler than with
when with a deterministic system
i have to admit that now problem four
was this one about points
getting pointy odd just specifying
points okay
the solution that i have here
is uh
starts out
uh line skip zero
baseline skip zero
this uh
means then that boxes are going to be
uh
are going to be plastered right next to
each other jammed right right next to
each other
i didn't discuss that in this course yet
but uh there's three there's there's
this the baseline skip is when when we
add some when we add something to a
vertical list and there was previously a
box in the list
the tech will calculate
interline glue
between
the
between boxes and the inner line glue
gets inserted between one box and the
next one in any vertical list now the
baseline skip tells how far
you want the baselines of those two
boxes to be
and
so we try to get the baseline skip b in
there
if we can now if this if this second box
is small then the inner line glue is the
amount of baseline skip minus the
depth and height of the of these two
adjacent boxes so that's the inner line
glue gets calculated there's also
stretching and shrinking in the inner
line glue that that's copied just from
the baseline skip which is zero
no plus here if i had said plus that
stretching shrinking gets
gets stuck in in there but the the main
part of it is the is is calculated so
that the baselines will come the right
distance apart the
um
on the other hand if this second box
were very tall went like that
then
this would not be a nice situation so
the boxes move down and instead and the
inner line glue is set to equal the line
skip glue in that case then there's a
question where do you decide to draw the
line because maybe you'd like to switch
to line skip glue if these boxes
if these boxes got close to each other
um that actually
arises in the eq align macro i i changed
the eq line macro and basic over the
weekend just because
i've been wanting to do it for a long
time but the but uh the thing was it it
it gives a little extra space between
lines in any in in a displayed formula
that's typical of in printing and uh
and so typically you'll have extra uh
the lines will open up a little bit so i
open up a line so that the baseline skip
is 15 points in
equal line instead of 12 and that was in
there for a long time in eq line
but
now what happens if these formulas
um actually
these boxes on two adjacent lines
were just so that uh they would come out
15 points apart
that would then uh it wouldn't look like
you were opening them up three extra
points so those lines would look like
they were just as close together as they
would be in a non-displayed formula so
uh
so there's a there's also a line skip
limit
and the new version of eq line sets the
line skip limit equal to three points
which means that you that if boxes come
within three points of each other then
you're going to add the line skip glue
which in this case is three points now
if you watch this as a continuous
function if the line skip
in the eq align i said baseline skip to
15 and the line skipped to three
and that meant that if the if the if the
space between boxes
was was uh between zero and three points
i was i i was i was not adding anything
to the to the uh uh sorry but as soon as
as soon as the boxes afterwards it
started growing
no i started annoying there was a jump
at uh
there was a jump at three points if the
boxes were three points apart
or or less than three points apart but
um essentially
they would be placed
let's see
just as they were yeah
50 yeah but if they were yeah yeah so
then all of a sudden it would jump all
of a sudden it would jump uh when they
were just uh when they were just
touching then they would then they would
then they would come three points apart
that's what it is so
um so i had this jump effect so i so if
i'm setting the line skip up high line
skip limit ought to be said hi the line
skip limit can also be set negative
which is i don't mind if boxes interfere
because maybe there's two lines that
have you know one of them comes down
here and the other one
comes up over here it doesn't really
they don't really clash and and so if
you sometimes you might want you might
need an application where you you like
the lines get limited be negative and
allow and allow this kind of overlap to
occur and but uh that's a little living
dangerously anyway the uh
there are these three things if if line
skip and baseline skip are both zero
you don't have to
worry about
uh line skip limit in any case they're
going to it's going to butt the boxes
together
because line skip is
because mind skip equals baseline skip
in both cases so so so the inner line
two would be zero in any case now this
is this is so that i can put several
boxes together in a row and not worry
about um
any baseline calculations or anything
being done but that was the the trick in
this but i should mention by the way
that someone that if you um tried to
solve these problems and didn't
get the answer you shouldn't feel bad
about it only feel bad if you didn't try
uh
but if you tried uh and didn't then then
i think that this deal your
the main point is to learn uh and to
prepare yourself to appreciate the
solution after afterwards uh they make
uh not not to discover it so much as to
as to get your mind prepared for this
kind of
this this this kind of input
i set the var unit to half an inch
because i was going to do everything in
vu and i also set a space at the top of
the page
so that i would start my my example six
vu's down from the top that's uh these
are kind of arbitrary things that is to
position the the origin but here was the
point macro so i delimited it by spaces
um as you see that's what the what what
the delimiters look like they are here
space the carriage return the charging
turn and space are equal
but i put a space afterwards so that
would read until to the end of a space
then
the main thing was to make a v box zero
points
high and zero points deep
uh they go
that's
that's both uh necessary
um
uh so i got gonna get it zero points
high
and do i have a zero point steep i
better
huh
i hope so otherwise it won't work let's
check it okay zero points high anyway um
and then i can put these v boxes after
each other but the v box is actually
going to going to skip around and put
the points in in the right place uh even
though it's something like the hide but
but worse
okay so now i i i do a v stretcher
shrink which will move up or down as
necessary and then i make a v box whose
height is the
is the second is the y coordinate
so um that's a so now i have a v box
whose height is the y coordinate here
that's the height of this second v box
whoops
that's the y-coordinate the second
coordinate
then um uh in that inside of that v box
what is there well there's an h box that
goes to vu to the right and then one vu
more that was just uh so that i wouldn't
fall off the left margin
uh so i added a little extra so but i'm
moving x to the right so i start out
with a box that's
that's um
that's uh this
that sort of x plus two to the right
uh then i typeset the thing so i said
dollar sign bullet thin space and gave
the coordinates close dollar sign
um and that was the end of the h box
also so then i put my bullet and the x y
here
and that's the h box
now what
then
um
what
happens then i put another vs
s
at the end at the end of this v box so
that this h box would move all the way
up to the top of the of the v box and so
that the depth of the v box would be
zero so this h bar this actually raises
up to the right right position
the um
the height of this h box is actually the
height of the right parenthesis and
if i had given a coordinate that was
that was something like 2 to the 2 to
the 2
it would have been higher and i probably
would have got the point in the wrong
position
so this isn't absolutely perfect well
then so that's what that vss does so
here i have an example where there's a
vss at the beginning of a v box and a
vss at the end of the v box now if you
don't understand the example
run it
and uh and and and trace the boxes that
get computed and and just look at the
boxes you know i showed you on monday
what the what the uh how the boxes are
constructed and you then you'll see i
think
so this made a box of zero height zero
with the and and if the reference point
of the box was there it actually
tech would go up y
to the right x and type set the x and y
all right
that was kind of a
trick but it just proves that you can
actually position things arbitrarily on
a page and so
i i first used this kind of a trick when
i was doing a family tree
uh where where the or a computer program
had computed the place where we wanted
to put everyone's name and address and
so on on the page um so then the macro
would just just position the box
containing the text of the of the names
and addresses
uh marriage dates and all that stuff in
in the right place
using some some idea like this one box
after another each one gets moved to the
right position
this is the fifth oh i got to talk about
the challenge problem
bit before
before we finish today so uh uh someone
said it was the challenge to figure out
how to how to tip the copy and and uh
and and cut it off here no that was just
this was just to show you that what the
what the file looks like there's a file
that was that's a consistent this is the
same uh
text that someone had used last week
that's that's where i got the idea from
uh
about uh
uh this uh saint paul writing about love
this uh but each verse starts with a uh
at sign in a space
and
not necessarily at the beginning of a
line but you could assume that if you
wanted to but anyway that's text file is
already in there so that those who want
to solve this problem can just don't
have to read and ends with flush page
macro
the uh
but the problem is uh is to get these
numbers in the right hand margin
uh in the middle of a paragraph so that
wherever there's a beginning of a new
verse the corresponding verse number
would would appear on that same line
now it's not hard in fact to to attach a
marginal note to the beginning of a
paragraph that would be a fairly simple
macro we could we at the beginning of a
macro we could have something that was
like hide except instead of hiding it at
the left we could you know we could we
could make a hbox to size and and then
stick something out in the in the right
hand margin uh
hbox par or something a bunch of notes
about that paragraph and that's what
most people
that's all most people need for for for
uh marginal notes
they just uh say well here's a note i'd
like to include with certain paragraph
and that would be a fairly easy macro to
add and uh it's used in a lot of books
less often does somebody want to give
marginal notes in the middle of a
paragraph and this is what this
challenge problem is where we're trying
to get the verse number in the middle of
of the paragraph and uh you can assume
that the that that there aren't two
there are three verse numbers in the
same line because in fact uh that never
occurred in the whole jerusalem bible
the jewish bible uses this format
and uh that's why i got this one this is
this is the jerusalem bible translation
i hope i haven't violated copyright
uh too badly um
this um
uh
this uh
is the
uh
the style that they use and they never
have to worry about more than two two
verses on a line um in fact the average
uh you typically go about two and a half
lines between verses but here was a case
where there were two on a line and
that's this case i set these numbers
eight points apart otherwise they're 12
points apart
and usually when you have two in a line
the next line isn't going to have two
either
so that i didn't have to i otherwise put
these six and seven a little closer
together to worry about two lines in a
row with two so i i'll assume that on
two consecutive lines you'll have in
most three verses that's my that's
that's a reasonable assumption that's
that's certain that's valid in the uh
in the in the bible the shortest person
the bible is jesus wept but it only
occurs once most of them are very small
very very often okay now um uh
the here just to show you that i was
getting different pages i i had this
first page and i had the second page uh
which
was fleshed out but of course this is a
rather
uh not a very big page but i didn't have
a very big example
i wanted to do that okay so that's the
problem and we'll discuss it more about
it tomorrow
tomorrow's topic is output routines
okay now um
right justify the following this is
exercise five
and uh
this was
a problem of trying to to uh devise a a
general purpose macro for people that
that didn't want to type a lot of tech
codes
so that they would just type the lines
that were to be right justified and the
carriage return would be enough to tell
tech that was it
okay so this is a change code up uh a
change code exercise and the code of
15 octal 15 is the carriage return and
changing that a carriage return to
another char
is necessary if you're going to
recognize again it recognize the
carriage return now this is a very
dangerous thing because carriage returns
are not only
end of line but they're they're somehow
built in to tech
that
you know you you get carriage returns
when you enter something from your
terminal they aren't all
exactly the same as other characters
and it's hard to end the line
of your instructions without hitting a
carriage return so you also have to be a
little careful of that well so i defined
it anyway and i started with par just uh
you know to get my make sure i was in
vertical mode then i then the macro when
it gets called it's going to change the
code of course with macro as i'm reading
it now is the this is this is just text
it's not the code is is still the
ordinary card return that's that's in
effect at this point but after the macro
is is active the code will be changed
then
after it changes the code then it does
this v skip minus 12 points
um that's because it's going to turn out
and i still don't know exactly why
oh i do but uh
the very first line is going to be blank
so it printed out one blank line and
this gets through this this backspace is
over that button over the blank line the
reason is that there's a carriage return
at the end of
of right justify the following that's
followed by a carriage return and that
carriage return
turns out to be to be detected it hasn't
been gobbled up yet after you change the
code to 12 that carry return is still
sitting there
just the fact that it was a non-letter
wasn't uh was it was enough to but it
stayed in the buffer
it didn't get flushed into a space i
i don't know why but it doesn't i
checked it again today you can see if
you can find
another example but i bet you it doesn't
now
when i'm calling the when i'm calling
right justify this is it this this goes
into the scanner it doesn't uh it
doesn't go into the mouth routine that
that says throw away the
turn you might think of another way but
this works
i'm going to need another one like this
so so one one more won't hurt me then i
said i have a routine called rjn which i
said to be r j that's for right justify
and r j n is is uh
is going to change later so i start out
and say let r j n equal r j initially r
j n is r j and then i call right justify
so the rj macro that's the record that's
the thing that's going to right justify
every line
and then i then
in order to define the rj macro i'm
going to define carriage return
to be a another char
and the rj macro is defined right there
and then quick before i
i got into more trouble i changed the
carriage return back to five again so
this is the definition of rj there are
those two lines but i had to change the
carriage return to five again before i
got to the end of another line otherwise
i get to things like undefined control
sequence i don't know no no it'll start
getting carriage returns in my output
file yes and i forget what they what
character they are yeah you've done that
okay so so i i quick i had to
temporarily change the code of 15 while
i was defining this macro but i quick
got rid of it again as soon as i could
and then and i i did a carriage return
right there so that carriage returns is
is the delimiter of the of parameter
number one so parameter number one and
the character turn after it is what's
going to gonna trigger to trigger this
whole thing okay now right justified
line
so after i get into the macro it's quite
simple like i call our just line on this
on the on the parameter and then i call
rjn
remember rjn is what i said he said
equal to rj
so
that will do it over and over and over
again
until
you get to
end right justify okay so now let's see
let's let's uh before i reveal the rest
of the answer because you have it there
in front of you but
you get to end right justify so android
testify is going in as the parameter to
rj so now we're calling rj of end right
justify
and it'll call our just line of end
right justify
and then it'll do rjn so what does
android justify want to do it wants to
print out a blank line back up one line
uh there's no way we've already called
largest lines we're going to align
whether we want to or not it's going to
back up one line because of that blank
line and then it's but we also going to
change
rjn so that rjn will now exit
something like that so
oh in fact i did that didn't do exactly
that i define and right justify to to
to change rjn to be nrj macro so
so
we get a right justified line of nothing
and then
rjn is now end rj so now we get out and
that's the the final concluding
thing is to change code carriage return
back to five and then uh skip back over
the the uh blank line that we ended with
that was the way to do it
question
here
justify the following
okay yes that's a good question suppose
so this was right justify the following
number one and then
end right justify okay something like
that now
um
there's there's two there's at least the
first problem with that is that that
you wouldn't dare do this definition
because then number one would be scanned
ignoring carriage returns
so you have to have a way of changing
the code of carriage return before
scanning number one so the first so
first of all you would have to define
right justify the following to be
something that changes the code and then
you would then and then you then you
could call another rja
macro or something after the code has
been changed that would that would read
in the parameter up to android justify
into number one and then that parameter
you you could that parameter then all
the carriage returns in that parameter
are those uh um
are coded as as uh and
uh and it would be difficult but
probably possible uh
because i think because i made a 12. you
could you could always just define at
the beginning
that the
character return is controlled sequence
for the first to find it just to be
carried
these are these are possible with very
uh uh
uh
uh tricky and and you can you can think
of examples where it doesn't where this
uh
uh it doesn't quite give you what you
want so so uh uh it would work on most
examples but this but the way i've done
it here is much less uh is much more
uh general now i want to get to number
six and we're running out of time but uh
you still have a question okay just a
quick question perhaps along the change
line if you would use the change code
carriage return 13
to be a
um
what is it a
car
null h fill
okay and then end right justify just
sets it back to what it's supposed to be
wouldn't that have worked at least on
the examples you have where there's at
most one line yes it would have that was
that's and that's very simple too
you have to also of course change the
power fill skip uh yeah and then car
indent to zero yeah but that's that
would do it so he's saying that the uh
that change every every carriage return
from then on into a
into a paragraph end
and and uh and then a paragraph
beginning and so on yeah that's
important alternative is to use line
break instead of par
line break instead of par
that uh
that would take quite a few lines uh
properly uh and uh
uh
not fill up too much the uh the memory
yeah
okay
so yeah the way i did it was probably uh
more tricky but i i believe uh it it
it probably is more robust also
now the last the last one and we only
have a minute or two this was the one to
get lines going up and down actually now
i
uh this this changing the code of the
dollar sign to 12 and back to three
again uh isn't really necessary i i when
i first wrote it i thought it was but
then thinking about afterwards i
realized that i'm only using it to match
up
to to look for a dollar sign at the end
of a text i'm putting a dollar sign in
at the end
at the end of of my parameter list and
then i'm i'm testing to see when i got
to the end uh here uh in these places
and that doesn't um
but the if test doesn't look to see what
the code is so so an ordinary math
parameter dollar sign would have been
would have been just as good in both of
these examples
it doesn't go into math mode unless you
actually parse it
question you've got the mic
tokens instead of no it doesn't it's no
i don't you know it doesn't care what
what they are
you think it should well i don't think
it should
okay but if it did then we would want
this to code here but uh it doesn't
right now anyway i know it just looks at
the at the character part
and make sure that it's a quote
okay now uh
um uh so line down and line up are very
very similar in this in this particular
solution it's a case of recursion where
i
where where this is an n squared
solution in other words if the length of
text that you're doing is of length n
then
we build it up uh
we reconstruct it by doing something
that builds one of the size one two
three up to n and and the total amount
of time is proportional to n squared
now i believe that's necessary for the
reversal thing but i but this but the
only difference really was then in one
place when i when i did an x step of
ants in one case i answered was going to
be the answer to this macro in one case
i i i changed ants into its previous
value followed by something carried
return in the second case i i preceded
by the other one so in one case i'm
reversing
the the uh the final order in one case
i'm not but otherwise the
the codes are identical and they're very
similar to what we discussed yesterday
that is uh you start you have a macro
that sets it up then it calls the other
macro with a delimiter at the end of the
parameters
the the other macro test to see if
you've got to the end if you have then
the next thing is just the answer if you
haven't then you you you
augment the answer and the next thing is
to repeat the this situation over and
over again
and that will uh
will produce then finally the answer as
a long
a long string of text it's a control
sequence but it's also a long string of
text and the long string of text is the
answer to the problem that you wanted
to produce by lying down now the bottom
is a is an alternate solution that for
line down
that would have worked without the in
order n instead of instead of order n
squared
and i would use
i would use uh this is exactly the same
text as in the beginning except i'm
calling line d n instead of line d o w n
um so that you can see the the line d n
macro
and the trick about this the only reason
this had to be more complicated
that i had to switch between
between this one and this one this one
calls
lndn lndn calls l-i-n-e-d-n and they
flip back and forth between each other
the reason is uh that that you have to
check before you get to the end to the
last line that you're at the at the end
a carriage return cannot be followed by
if
without
without tech assuming that there's going
to be some there's going to be a missing
carriage return on the next line so we
had to put so this this is a
this efficient solution is just shown
there for those who who would try the
case where these two were equal and not
flipping you're going to get an error
message so on the last line of that
alignment saying that the
because there was an if following a
carriage return
this was expanding the thing as it went
instead of building up the answer
i believe
in fact why did i g def ends to be null
oh
you